The next thing we did to increase the speed of the site was we added another database,
and this was using a piece of software called Slony, I believe, to replicate our database.
We still only had one app server at this time, and we made lots of database requests.
Our caching was not nearly as advanced.
We had some basic caching, it was just at the application level.
This machine was hitting both of these Postgres machines.
This is the first time we ran into the notion of replication lag,
because we have these two separate machines, and Slony would normally keep them in sync,
but sometimes, the slave machine could lag by about 5 seconds or so.
If you had just submitted the link and then we redirected you to the permalink,
and then we'd hit the slave machine that didn't have the permalink we would send the user a 404,
which is really annoying right after you submitted a piece of content.
That's when we started thinking about writing to our cache
at the same time as writing to our database.
We also had the issue with these two processes of keeping these caches in sync.
We weren't using memcached yet--the way we kept our caches in sync
was we used the library called Spread, and Spread is this network library that basically says
if you send a message to one host, it will send it to all of these other hosts.
Around this time was when we added our second app server
that was running Python on as well, and we used Spread to keep the two hash tables
that we were using as our cache kind of in sync.
This worked sort of okay in terms of keeping these two caches in sync,
but it wasn't going to scale very well, because eventually, we would add
a couple of more app servers to deal with more load and Spread
like every time one of these app servers would update its cache,
you would have to tell all of the other app servers about it and so turned in to the huge mess,
a lot of network traffic keeping all of these caches in sync.
It was a total mess, and so eventually, we would switch to memcached,
but that was not before we rewrote our database.
Shortly after we switched a couple of machines and a couple of databases, we added comments,
and the first version of comments--it was just another database table.
There's nothing complicated about it--it had a link ID of what link it was on
and had some contents, author ID--you can kind of guess the columns it would have,
and we still did lots of joins--it was a relational database.
We changed around this time to a more flexible database architecture,
or at least a more flexible table design, because the challenge we had
was every time we added a new feature, you might have to add a new table
or you might add a new column to one of these tables.
Adding a column would take time, and we might have to do a data migration
or update an index and add all these load--it was just a total pain.
We felt like the rate at which we could add features was limited
by our ability to update our database and to do these big migrations.